- C'est une rare incursion
défigurée. Une ville en ruine
où lufufuffrance habite
chaque petit recoin.
Les habitants de Marioupol
déambulent dans les rues
Ilntntnt épuisés, malades,
désorientés et surtout affamés.
Ça fait plus d'un moi
qu'ils sont privés de tout,
enfermés comme des animaux
"On est sans électricité,
sans eau, sans gaz, sans pain",
crie Tamara de sa fenêtre."
"On nous a donné du macaroni,
dit-elle, mais on doit
le manger cru. Aidez-nous,
Marioupol est coupée du monde
L'aide humanitaire, longtemps
paralysémemememence à peine
arriver, mais c'est le strict
minimum. Il faut faire la file
pour une miche de pain
et pour de l'eau.
"On a besoin de viande,
dit cette femme, de poisson
pour rester en forme,
ne pas perdre nos dents
c'est pour ne pas qu'on crève",
ajoute-t-elle.t t t t t t t t ts
dans une ville fantôme."
Ces images et ces témoignages
ne sont qu'un aperçu
du d
"Nous n'avons plus d'endroit
oùNous sommes chez nous,
sans travail, sans maison,
sans rien. Qui va vouloir
de nous?"
Beaucoup n'ont même où dormir.
Ils se c d d d d d d d d d d d r
les yeux, le temps d'oublier
leur cruel destin. La fatigue,
les pires des supplices pour
ceux qui césésésésésésespérément
leurs proches. n n n n n n n n ,
dit le texte sur l'affiche. Nous
t'attendons à cette adresse."
En espérant qu'Anatole soit
encore e
Natalia aussi cherche sa fille.
Elle est i 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 t
été tués, selon le maire del,l,e
à l'extérieur de la ville.
L'armée russe contrôle
maintenant plus de 80 % de la
ville et tout son pa
thththththththththththththththts
qu'une ruine hantée par la mort.
Notre équipe guidée par
l'art t t t t t t t tout juste
d'y découvrir les corps calcinés
d'une femme et d'un enfant.
Ils étaiennnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnocents
qui s'étaient, comme tant
d'autres, réfugiés ici pour
Ce soldat russe nie encore
"Le théâtre n'a pas été
bombardé, dit-il, l'explosion
est survenue à l'intérieur.
On a des preuvesbibibibibibibibs
se cachent sous les décombres?
Celui qui a été désigné chssssse
l'ignore.
Il dit que deux équipes
le terrain pour les entreposer
dans des réfrigérateur
ou dans des morgues.
ils sont dans nos jardins",cece.
Il espère qu'un jour,
avec dignité, une fois
ésésésésésésésésésés.
Ce qui reste de résistance
ukrainienne à Marioupol estxexe.
Et les combats, telle
une guérilla urbaine,
Mais plus pe..........C'est la e
du calvaire quotidien,
de leur apocalypse